so on behalf of the entire office of the
arts uh
we'd like to welcome you and thank you
all so much for being here for the 15k
creative arts competition pitch finale
my name is shannon rose mcauliffe and
i'm the manager of the student arts
programs here at mit
hi i'm fedo fields i'm a first year mba
student at mit sloan and the
graduate assistant at the office of the
arts helping with this competition
so tonight is our ninth annual pitch
finale for the 15k
since 2013 the 15k has served as an
incubator
for creative entrepreneurial startups
and it's helped dozens of student teams
to grow their ideas into influential
businesses that live at the intersection
of arts and
innovation we had 10 creative
entrepreneurship ventures advanced
through
the preliminary rounds of feedback the
competition this year
throughout the whole process these teams
have shown amazing progress and have
demonstrated
an impressive collaborative attitude
often working together and getting to
know one each other beyond just the
means of competing
they should all the teams who competed
this year should be commended
their flexibility their perseverance and
their integrity in the midst of
upheaval this year in a very uncommon
year
so following the first round of judging
we have five finalist teams who have
emerged for a chance to win
fifteen thousand dollars towards
supporting their projects
we're really really quite proud of their
diligence
their hard work and we're very excited
tonight to announce that
everyone pitching tonight will walk away
with at least one thousand dollars to
support their ventures
it's been a privilege to witness the
growth that each team has undergone on
their journey to get here this afternoon
um i mean the competition was
essentially designed to provide benefit
to creative ventures
at all stages so it's important to note
that all of these teams were offered to
experience these three key aspects of
the 15k
so firstly we've got idea development
and workshops
we started this year's competition with
a kickoff keynote
and mini conference including a talk by
wendy and jen who are here tonight from
creative reframe
and this was followed by a panel
discussion with previous competitors and
mentors from the 15k
following that we launched a five-part
workshop series that really
assisted teams who were in the initial
phases of their ventures
and these topics spanned value
propositions
budgets and business plans um
then during the independent activity
period in january we ran a four-week
course that was aimed at helping
ventures to learn how to write more
coherently and persuasively about their
businesses
so then we got into the application
phase following the initial applications
each team reserve received thorough
feedback from very seasoned arts
professionals and
entrepreneurs so through these
cumulative experiences we kicked off the
whole 15k
our team started to grow their ideas and
their business acumen
and this all started to happen on a much
more broad scale
and following that these workshops were
augmented by a more
thorough um and granular individual
mentorship
exactly a mentorship is the second
component that all the teams were able
able to access
and so all of the teams experienced
one-on-one mentorship sessions
with distinguished mit faculty alumni
creative entrepreneurs
artists attorneys marketing specialists
industry leaders i think that's all of
them but there's probably more
more categories that we could include
there um and all these people provide
nuanced insights and expertise helping
the teams develop their projects
this all happened and we really
appreciate a platform called mentorly
the 15k and mentor have been working
together for several years now and
they've been incredibly helpful in
assisting us with the data
and scheduling management as well as
stewardship and mentoring
helping steward everyone through the
mentorship process
the teams that competed this year
cumulatively undertook 27 rigorous
one-on-one mentoring sessions
with the experts that i've mentioned
before this is in addition to
the rounds of feedback that they got the
workshops that we did and the mock pitch
events that we held
and you know following that a very
integral element
of the 15k competition comes down to
this one concept and it's about
networking it's connections our student
teams make connections with other
students
with alumni and with industry mentors
and this network
continues to support them even after
they graduate as they continue to seek
ideas and opportunities and funding to
help bring their ideas to fruition
so this year's process which culminates
in today's pitch finale
would not have been possible without the
expertise guidance
and support from the mit community and
everybody who has been a part of this
year's 15k
um i'd like to acknowledge our
application feedback team
our mentors and our semi-final round
judges they volunteered their time
knowledge resources and really expert
insights throughout this entire process
we also ran those five fantastic
workshops that i alluded to before
and we've got people who are affiliated
with the martin trust center they like
gotham center
ohio state university athlone artists
and creative reframe and uh of course
we thank mentor lee as theo mentioned
for providing us with constant support
and an online platform that helps to
facilitate and track our entire mentor
process
moving on my extreme gratitude to my
colleagues in the office of the arts for
their insight their support
and for graciously assisting me with
prove it's
presenting what is yet another virtual
event
i didn't think we'd be doing this this
way again and i sure couldn't be doing
it without them so thank you to all of
you
and a huge thank you to michael and
maria
they are team elements they were our
2020 winner
and when the judges go off into
deliberation after the pitches tonight
uh elements is going to give you an
update about the really fantastic and
exciting things that they've been doing
since last year's 15k
and finally we've got a group of
phenomenal guests who have joining us
tonight
for our judging panel so without further
ado we're going to introduce each of
them now
so yeah the first we'll introduce is
michael camp in addition to teaching me
my first entrepreneurship class
he is also an entrepreneur and educator
and investor with extensive experience
designing interdisciplinary experiential
educational programs and
entrepreneurship
this program has launched hundreds of
entrepreneurial careers in dozens of
different product market verticals
including energy artificial intelligence
biotechnology
software medical devices fashion arts
and entertainment so now we've got
jen gilliman jen is a faculty member at
northeastern university's college of
arts media and design and she's the
co-founder of creative reframe
which is a startup that partners with
universities to integrate the arts and
innovation
and since the pandemic jen has become a
tree and bird enthusiast
and she's working hard these days to
learn how to tell the difference between
a grackle and a crow which i still can't
do so
good job jen next up is janan avenatti
janae is the executive director of the
mit sandbox innovation fund program she
brings a unique combination of
experiences from academic research
to senior operational strategic roles in
startup companies and large enterprises
she's also held leadership roles in two
of the largest
and most successful startups in boston
area ita software
and kayak jan is also an avid volunteer
at your children's schools including
being a founding member of the shady
hill schools center of arabic culture
thanks janan next up we have christine
armstrong christine
is an educator a scholar activist a
cultural strategist
mentor and woman of color who is
committed to centering access
equity and inclusivity through this work
christine has been recognized as a
subject matter expert
and thought leader for her commitment to
community
and to steering its effort towards
self-empowerment and social equity
in january 2021 christine joined boston
university's innovate at bu team as the
project manager there
program manager excuse me and leslie
university's graduate school of
education as an adjunct instructor
the final judge that we'll introduce
tonight is guillermo kondas gee is a
filmmaker photographer living and
working in new york
in sao paulo brazil he is currently the
creative director of lobo studios in new
york
he has directed numerous projects from
tv spots to interactive content for
clients including disney slash pixar
google giovanni pepsi and audi
he's worked with major production
companies around the world and has a
short film and his short films have been
featured in countless
international film festivals all right
so
before we commence with this evening's
pitches i'm gonna go over a little bit
of housekeeping i know that we're all
zoom experts by now but i would be
remiss not to say anything so
for attendees competitors and judges
alike
please keep your audio muted and go
ahead and pop off camera unless you are
actively speaking
each team is gonna have five minutes to
pitch we'll have five minutes for
questions from the judges
and then we'll have about a minute's
buffer and transition time between these
pitches
we're endeavoring to adhere to these
time schedules as closely as we can
and please note that we may intervene
gently via chat or with a verbal
reminder if things are going off course
so please don't be alarmed if all of a
sudden you hear
shannon rose ex machina's voice coming
in through
the um through your pitch so
after the five pitches judges are going
to exit for a roughly 45 minute
deliberation period
and then you the audience will have an
opportunity to ask
questions of our teams and you'll hear
an update from our 2020 winner
team elements if you have any questions
for the teams throughout the event
go ahead and submit them through the
chat or hold on to them for this q a
period following the pitches
so before we get started and before
everybody just pitches
cold let's do a quick roll call so teams
please come on camera and give us a wave
when you're called
and we've got team volar first
hi ignacio hi everyone then we're gonna
go with
fermentation heritage project
hello everyone hello
there we are there's jessica um next
zeki road
hello everyone how's it going doing
alright of bogu how you doing
we're really excited to hear your pitch
next we've got
rivet hi everyone
thanks for coming yep good to see you
and finally we've got sita with caso
hi everyone excited to share casa with
you all
excellent thank you all for that quick
intro it was nice to sort of start to
put a name to the face before we get
rolling
and with that we are going to
start with our pitch and i believe that
means ignacio you are up
just let us know when you're ready to
roll you should be able to share your
screen
and when you're ready to go let us know
so we can start time
perfect all right let's go all right
take it away so creators and artists in
latin america are desperate to live of
their passion
and turn side hustles into careers
let me tell you about romina cycling
romina is from mexico and she's
passionate about female empowerment
she's a fashion designer she's also an
author romina has an audience of around
100 000 followers on instagram
that follow her because they really love
the content that she produces
so we've been talking to romina a lot
and she tells us that she's desperate to
turn her passion into a sustainable
career
right now romina primarily makes most of
her money through
ads and brand sponsorships which take a
big cut of the revenues
and also force her to dilute her passion
because she has to become more
marketable
at the same time romina knows that she
has to diversify her revenues
but she lacks the business expertise to
know what to do
and she also doesn't have enough time to
focus on that
so this is where bolar comes in we
empower creators and artists like romina
with the software and business tools to
monetize her audience
in the long term we want to become the
one-stop shop where creators and artists
manage and grow their business
so right now we're helping romina in
three main ways first
we provided the business expertise to
understand what to sell to her audience
and at what price
secondly we allow her to set up ver very
easily set up a mobile optimized website
on our platform where she can sell
things directly to her fans
and thirdly we take off anything that's
to do with logistics payments scheduling
completely off her plate
so right now romina is offering
one-on-one mentorships and also some
group experiences
so for example with the one-on-one
mentorships she she can do 60-minute
sessions with her
with her audience where she can talk
about things like how to become a
fashion designer
um how like certain obstacles that women
may encounter in the workplace
how to grow an audience and on social
media she charges around sixty dollars
for that for those experiences
and uh bolar would take around 15 to 20
cut of
of that so we launched the two-week
pilot with with romina and the results
were amazing so in just two weeks romina
generated one thousand dollars in in
revenue
out of those 55 percent were repeat
sales she also saw 100
npns for both the the fan side and the
on her own so she was very satisfied
and also we had very favorable organic
dynamics from the creator side so we saw
20 new creators and artists asking to
join our platform
completely organically so that was at
zero dollars crater acquisition cost
and out of these 20 creators we have now
onboarded four with which we're learning
we're launching a
a new pilot
so just like romina there's 12 12
million other creators and artists in
latin america who are desperate to turn
their passion into a career the artists
that we're targeting have three
traits in common first they have a
passion for a specific topic and a
knowledge that they can really share
with with the audience
secondly they already have a
pre-existing audience typically between
50 000 to 200
000 followers so they're not celebrities
but they're also not just
starting off and thirdly they are
completely under
underserved so they don't have the tools
to monetize their audience
most of the existing tools are either
optimized for creators and artists in
other countries like for example the us
and also
often favor creators are more in like
the celebrity stage of the artist life
cycle
so this is a very there's a very big
market opportunity in latin america it's
four billion
uh four billion dollars in in latin
america with the more than 20
annual growth driven by the increase in
internet penetration
digital payments and very favorable fan
engagement metrics
so there's there's also a huge latent
supply and demand that will make this
market even bigger as it starts to
develop more
so these numbers are for latin america
overall our beachhead market and where
we will be starting off is
what we already started is mexico
also we're the perfect team to tackle
this market and conquer the and help the
creators
in latin america so i will be focusing
on go to market and strategy i have
experience working in uh strategy
consulting
rafaela is from brazil and will be
leading branding and marketing
trudy and dp are engineers from mhmit
and we'll be focusing on the product
and mauricio mateo and lindsay will be
dealing with operations and the
day-to-day with
creators and just to close it off i'd
like to ask you to join us to help
empower creators in latin america to
live off their passion
with 15k will really help us enhance our
product that we already have made
an mbp for and also keep optimizing our
creator acquisition engine so that we
can help
keep helping more and more people in in
latin america thank you so much and
please let me know if you have any
questions
all right fantastic ignacio why don't we
have you come off of screen share so
that we can have some q a with the
judges who can feel free to
uh come on camera at this time here we
go janan why don't we go with you
yeah great presentation so clear and you
just make it look so easy
so i'm going to talk to you a little bit
about what may be hard
so how hard was it to help
your initial creators
to actually uh gain revenue how much
work was that
yeah so the the bulk of the work was
before we
we launched with with romina so we spent
a lot of time doing
pmr and really understanding her pain
points and figuring out what
would uh would help her like increase
revenue and
after interviewing her a lot of other
creators we thought that trying out
something directly with fans like what
we did
would be the the right solution that was
the the bulk of the work
then he initially sort of creating a
profile for her which you can sell
directly to her fans
um and like coming up with the with the
ideas
that that of the stuff that she wants to
offer was not uh super time consuming so
that was like a one or two day uh
exercise uh and it has been the same for
the four other creators that we've
imported already so
from the time that we first get in touch
with our creator uh to when they
actually live
it's usually like a one to three day uh
period so it's
it's very fast
uh this is michael following up on that
question yeah thank you nice
presentation
uh following up on that question do you
have a sense of
how much you would have invested in
getting a creator online and to what
extent you use that information to set
the 15 to 20
profit share uh price point for the team
for the
for the company yeah so to
just to clarify when you say invested
you mean more like how much do i was
spending to acquire
a creator or yeah well yeah it would be
first of all cost to
identify them but then i actually
onboard them to get their
their platform set up to get everything
that they need in order to
to do the work so yeah
yeah so in terms of specific numbers
right now we
we haven't spent any money apart from
our own time to to
to make that happen and so all the the
coding that we've done to carry the
websites has been
in-house using no-code tools and then uh
all the acquisition has been
pretty organic so usually well we had
romina then she launched and all the
other creators coming in
came completely organically so we didn't
spend any money uh
there so it's mostly a time
for our time commitment initially and
now we're going more in like a concierge
type
approach as we as we finalize the the
the product um so i think the 15 to 20
we've justified it more in terms of like
comparison to
what they're experiencing in other
places rather than like our own
expenditure right now because that's
likely to change and
for example if the creator runs an ad on
instagram
instagram takes a hundred percent of the
of that revenue and uh
youtube takes 50 and if they launch with
an agency which is the more traditional
way of like dealing with uh any sort of
creative work like this
they take anywhere between 60 to 80
so for us that 15 to 20 range is a huge
decrease and given the numbers in terms
of revenue that we've been seeing
uh like the increase that can provide to
them we think it's like identify a way
for us to like scale and grow
as fast as we want to
you excellent i think we have time for
one more so
jen please go ahead thank you so much
and i love that you're focusing on
helping um creators directly the
question that i have for you
is about um you're working it sounds
like mostly with influencers and so
these would all be
probably people who already have a
following online is that correct yeah
that's right so influencers is a word
that we titled not to use because
it's it it has connections of a
different type of creator
so for us it's someone that has a
passion and a knowledge that they can
share
but yes they do have a pre-existing
audience yeah sorry i interrupted
thank you and i i don't know if we have
time but it sounds like with your
one kind of example you talked about
doing these one-on-one
services and then are you are you
looking to expand audiences or could you
give one other example
of i mean advertisement but is there
anything else that
you could see as part of the package in
terms of how we
help uh creators make uh yeah so
most of the most like our starting point
is those one-on-one
mentorships but something that we've
already started to try is more focused
on
group experiences and these are like
five to 20
uh like group sessions where where um
where people sort of would pay less of a
like
the price ticket would be lower and so
it's more likely that you'd have a
bigger volume and sometimes
we're trying to see if it makes sense to
organically have brands also sponsoring
these five to 50 to 20
uh people group experiences where uh
let's say like romina does like a
a conversation around cocktail making or
fashion within a certain industry and
like
a brand sponsors that uh then like they
would be able to have an extra
pop-up in terms of the revenue in a very
organic way without becoming a
an ad or like a brand it would be
something very organic
but in terms of like helping them grow
to new audiences as we've added new
creators in this new pilot
that we launched uh we've seen already
some like i don't know how to call it
like cross-pollination where
some of the audience from the other
creators went into our platform and saw
what romina was offering and started to
request things from
from her so as we have more creators
there will be more like interchanging
between the different audiences that are
existing already and that will help all
of them grow
all right and with that that
commence that uh concludes our q a with
voila thank you so much for that pitch
ignacio and now we are going to get
ready
for charlene and jessica from
fermentation heritage project
good afternoon everyone we're here to
bring
food fermentation back to our home and
our community
when i was growing up in my
grandmother's kitchen kept a ceramic jar
that sits humbly
on the counter and every time she cooked
she would add a little bit from that jar
into her dishes
and it created this wonderful rich umami
flavor
in all the meals that she'd made it was
a flavor on my childhood
and of my east asian heritage and the
flavor came from the magic of
fermentation
however due to the rapid rise of
processed food industry
the art the tradition and the flavor of
fermentation
is slowly disappearing and that is why
we want to bring back fermentation with
a modern touch
and we create an intelligent
fermentation chamber
most of you guys would probably have
fermented food either this morning or
something this week
in the form of yogurt craft beer
kombucha or even kimchi
but fermented food is so much more
fermentation
actually forms the backbone of many
cultural flavors such as miso in japan
tempeh indonesia and bacon sauce in my
hometown
china the process of fermentation
is actually pretty complex a mix of
chemical reactions
with different microbiomes but you can
think of it as cooking
than by little microscopic chef and as
they cook they unlock more nutrients in
food
while providing a natural source of
probiotic it is a plant-centric
way of creating food which is healthy
for us and also for the planet
it is a natural way of preserving
so the challenge of fermentation is
keeping the right environment
throughout the entire process if the
environment is off
we're risking underdeveloped flavor or
potentially worse food spoilage
and that is why we created our
fermentation fermentation chamber
to control and monitor the environments
throughout the entire process
it will provide precise temperature
humidity and earphone control
with azure monitoring designed to
fit a variety of different vermin and
with the companion app
we have simple pre-programmed sitting
for beginners to try out different type
of fermentation method
and also custom control for culinary
artists
to test and develop their own flavor
currently existing device are too
specialized and limiting such as yogurt
maker or kombucha maker
our product will be the first to provide
a control environment for a wide range
of fermentation
so our initial focus is aimed at the
fermentation community
which we estimate to be around half a
million people these are folks
that are already familiar with the
fermentation process and they're already
diying their own setups
we'll later expand to restaurant and
everyday home cooks
this is a really good time for
fermentation because there's a growing
trend
in healthy eating and probiotic diets
and we really want to be part of that
excitement
so we started out by reaching to our
target group of
passionate fermenters to understand if
there was demand for our device
through online presence and user survey
we have over 50 beta testers
waiting to try out our product we also
hosted
a mit event to introduce fermentation to
the local community
there was a high level engagement from
the attendees and they gave really
valuable
insights into what hesitations they had
towards getting started
we're now in the process of refining our
prototype
our first milestone is to get 10 beta
devices
sent out to our volunteer testers
we estimate the cost of producing these
beta devices to be around 13 000
and that's why we're requesting funding
we're also preparing to showcase our
device at the boston vermin festival
later next year
our plan is to become a bee corporation
with a mission
to keep the practice of fermentation
alive and so we are also
sourcing authentic miso and soy sauce
starters from japan
to provide to our customers and to
support the entire ecosystem and
tradition
we are a team with strong technical and
business background
we are patent holders and we have supply
chain experience our east asian heritage
also gives us really personal connection
to the project
we want to recreate the magic in our
childhood kitchens
and make our grandmothers really proud
food is our common ground a universal
experience
and that's why we believe the culture
and the art
of creating food through fermentation is
really worth preserving
thank you
all right that was fantastic and just
like
everybody else we're going to invite you
to stop screen share and then we'll have
our judges come back on camera
and we will have some q a
feel free to jump in with any questions
i know it's always
awkward to see if anybody else is gonna
speak first but it looks like
christine's gonna go
thank you so much for a great
presentation i was just curious if you
could speak a little bit more to the
problem at hand
the specific pain points i love the
innovation behind the solution but i'm
not quite sure what the existent problem
is
and therefore who the target customer
might actually be
all right i can speak on that so i can
go into if you know my i'll share screen
again i can talk a little bit more in
detail
so for each type of fermentation the
trick is that traditionally when it's
done
it's left in the environment at a
certain season at that particular region
for example
in the environment of a human summer day
in japan
or in indonesia or in west africa in
order for certain type of ferment to
perform the best and develop the flavor
however it's hard to recreate the same
environment
if you're in boston in the middle of
winter
to create the same human environment to
make your food and develop the flavor
that's what i want the pinpoint is one
thing that we want to be able to do is
actually create the one thing that we're
doing right now is that our chamber will
simulate the environment and create the
environment it is for
the little microbiome chef to prosper
and like create the flavor and simulate
the environment where the traditional
ferments made
and that is the pinpoint currently
happening right now right and to add on
to that
the existing devices on the market
they're very specialized
if you want to make yogurt okay you can
get a yogurt maker but if you want to
make soy sauce or miso you don't really
have a device that could do that
you can try to attempt to make it in
your oven but that's
very uncontrolled and very volatile so
we want to give really a controlled
environment to give
a wide variety of like fermentation
options
thank you
all right any other questions
and yeah it's so good to see you jessica
and charlene on the
whole new technology here not surprising
uh so good to see you so i'm just
curious so you
want you've got an established market of
consumers that do want to
ferment because that's you know
something they've been doing it's part
of their family tradition
um but this is you know the topic of
fermentation and
how good it's for the health is so big
have you looked at
potentially looking at restaurants that
may um
think this would be a good a good thing
to have because they're producing
food at a much larger scale and it's a
good selling point
yeah that's actually a question that
we're considering uh
i will share screen again so recently
bon appetit did a survey of the funky
new restaurant that came up that
incorporated fermented food across the
united states and this is like a
category of the picture
now of course boston uh we're also very
conscious
health conscious now and people start
realizing how important it is to have a
good
good house and also eat well those are
the target restaurants that we have
already identified
that has the potential to adapt our
technology and definitely a group of
people want to reach out to in our
secondary market
all right i'm taking a look uh right
we're back in gallery does anybody do
any of our other judges have any other
questions
if i could i would just want to know
it's probably too early
but i wonder if you have a sense of what
this device might
sell for in a consumer application not
the restaurant application
do you have a feel for where that is
yeah yes we
uh this is a little bit of a trickier
question because
from a prototype standing point when you
prototype a device
the cost of the prototype is vastly
different when you go up to scale
manufacturing
but we do have a good estimate in terms
of connection with local
manufacturer uh in some of the products
and some of the
components we're gonna source and how
much that's gonna cost when we do scale
up
very good i'd be more interested in
understanding the value
price point as opposed to the cost plus
price point but
i'm sure you'll get there as you work
forward thank you nice job
all right if we don't have any other
questions
i'll give another two seconds speak now
judges
forever hold your piece any questions
right
fermentation i just wish we would have
had a sample
no i know i could really go for some
kimchi right now especially after that
pitch
um okay since it looks like we don't
have any further questions at this
moment
why don't we go ahead and move on to
a bogu with azeki road
good evening everyone my name is obogu
and we are
azeki road so to start i want to
introduce you to tayo
the founder and creative director of
corporate culture a premium menswear
brand based in lagos nigeria
with international ambitions to his
title's words
he wants to see corporate culture in
every single closet
as many classes as possible um and is
actually one of our first customers
now given that vision when it comes to
being able to execute and realize that
vision
tayo has his challenges because he as
well as many other african designers
lack the operational capacity and
support to be able to really realize
their potential
specifically when it comes to being able
to demonstrate and convey
their brand's value directly to their
global audiences
when it comes because of the
deficiencies the fragmentation
the inability to handle the organization
of functions such as production
brand experience as well as distribution
they are unable to really tap
into their potential now this matters
for two reasons the first being that
ohio and many other designers can serve
as significant economic
engines for the countries that they're
based in given the fact that the value
of the african luxury fashion market
is at 3 billion and is growing but more
significantly more important
barge incumbent brands have historically
and continue to
leverage the various styles aesthetics
and designs
of these brands limiting the value that
taiyo and many others can capture for
themselves
and inadvertently proving that there is
a global demand for
these brands so given this as well as
given the shifts that we're seeing
such as the rise of digital commerce as
well as the space being there for
newer more authentic brands to capture
and
uh global attention our focus has been
how might we enable tile as well as
others in the space to capture more the
value that they create
now based upon our research which
includes interviews
on field studies as well as talking to
other stakeholders in the system
our approach is to build technology
solutions that take on
and strengthen the direct-to-consumer
operations on behalf of these brands
and essentially serve as the
infrastructure through which taiyo
and many others can do business
effectively now
specifically starting with the brand
experience first given how critical that
is we're building a digital brand
assistant
that aggregates the various tools and
touch points that taiyo will need to
interact with his global consumer into
one place
leverage machine learning to be able to
help him understand what drives brand
love
in the business and provide
recommendations to ease the process of
him being able to make the right
decisions
to grow and capture value now to bring
it
bring it home and make it more concrete
prior to engaging with us taiyo did not
have the capacity
to operate a digital commerce business
whatsoever
uh but through the use of our working
prototype we have helped him understand
what drives genuine engagement between
his consumers and the brand
and has therefore not only helped stand
up his digital commerce business
in the middle of the pandemic but has
also increased traffic by three times
and now we're starting to see digital
sales through that platform that didn't
exist before
now in exchange for a service we
implement a revenue share model to
align ourselves with the success of
these brands starting at 15
in exchange for this digital brand
assistant and brand experience service
and with the intention to increase that
percentage as we
execute our vision and build more
solutions that address the
value chain now it's important to really
ground
the conversation and make it clear that
for taiwan many
designers from the continent their
options are limited but when it comes to
uh providing the comprehension
comprehensive support that they need
at the degree of control that they
desire we're positioning ourselves to be
the only company to be able to do this
given the fact that our only alternative
is working with marketplaces and really
retail shops that
are somewhat helpful ultimately limit
the amount of value that tayo
and many others can really capture when
it comes to growing the brand
uh anis matilda and i have a wealth of
experience across consumer
goods retail and especially fashion with
operational
experience across design technology
operations and strategy
as well as the personal connections to
the continent that serves as the
motivation for us to want to see these
brands
thrive and capture the value that they
really do deserve to do so
now in addition to our corporate culture
we're also
currently bringing on two more brands
for our platform both based in ghana
including dua becerra who's been
featured in vogue italia as well as
vanity fair
and really leveraging our customer
interactions to really refine our
offering
as well as the rest of our platform in a
customer-centric approach
and when it comes to the 15k really
we're looking to use this to
upscale our working prototype and
improved
our digital brand assistant to handle
this scale conduct further experiments
to really validate the value that we're
bringing to these brands
and start seeding the process of
beginning that research
to see what else can we build to address
the
rest of the value chain so thank you we
are azeki road
we are where expression thrives and we
welcome you to follow us
fantastic all right well
that was really wonderful why don't we
have you stop your screen share so that
we can get into our judge q a
all right yee looks like you've got your
hand up
yeah so um great presentation and i took
a look at some of the brands
uh before your presentation here today
and
i really love like the style and the the
brands you guys
have their feels like really interesting
really fresh
and my question is like really about
that because we talk about fashion we're
talking about style
and each place will have like a
different sense of style
um so right now uh those brands
might have like some uh i i would assume
like those brands already have a name
for themselves like in
in africa maybe like in their own
countries but not necessarily like
pan-african
and like other places so do you see this
uh how do you see that that connection
is that like
first uh widening the reach within
africa and then there is like a second
stage where this will come forward
to america which seems to have like
it's a ripe market but it feels like
it's a fashion sense that
americans didn't catch up to that yet
maybe you know what i mean
like how do you see that yeah so
actually
so a couple of things so in terms of our
general approach
um our approach is like especially with
the digital branding system which is our
media focus right now we're building a
tool to essentially help
these brands identify their core
customer
in a way that even transcends not just
their local
uh environment but in other countries is
even internationally as well
because uh and for more context
duabacero especially already has
international clients
so does heal the world um so to the
second point
there is at least proof within the brand
that we work with and with many others
that
that uh are like been featured on the
slide that their ability to transcend
into global audiences we're just giving
them the ability to be able to do that
with the level of
data driven intention that many brands
here based in the west as well as the
large incumbents have as well
so it's a matter of us leveraging our
technology
for them to be able to make those
connections easier given the fact that
they already already have
whether it be aesthetically or even
through actual business dealings the
proof to be able to
make that leap so in other words you
already identified as
uh aesthetic connection and you believe
that the technology would enable
uh that kind of style to go reach like
the right eyes in the right pocket so
people could uh actually like
you know like wow this is amazing i love
those shoes you know like i can't find
this in america
but there's like this guy and now for me
is easy to buy this from
um you know be nigeria or ghana okay yes
exactly
um
very good anything from any of our other
panel members jen take it away
i just have a question about the
audience is this really kind of ho
couture for like
very kind of fashion savvy people or do
you see this as also being a market for
you know other audiences and what do
they you know in way of the price point
who who's your target audience so
our so our ezekiel specific target
audience
um are these brands i guess when it
comes to consumer
it's really up to the brand so like the
way that we work is that
we're we just simply serve as a back end
for these brands so
or is it actually a perfect example the
through corporate culture duabacero and
heal the world
they actually do span span like
different segments where
dwa becerra is very much in that
high-end couture space and that's the
clientele that nelly who's the founder
is like
targeted in and where she wants to go
taiyo is really specifically
focused on younger young like young
adults young professionals which of
course is a
much different like less pricey uh
uh price point so it's really the way we
see ourselves is basically
the brand the designer still ultimately
decides where the brand goes
they're the creative director they using
the vision we just
provide the infrastructure and structure
for them to be able to execute that
so we're really beholden to whatever
they choose to feel the target now
depending upon our insights we also are
able to provide some advisory in terms
of okay
perhaps there's this specific segment
that you might need to focus on but
ultimately it's
the thank you no problem
we have just under a minute left if
anybody has any other questions
i'll give you all a second oh christine
sure i have one
a bit on kind of the the social impact
question curious are you only targeting
artisans that are already
established or are you also looking to
use this platform to uplift
up-and-coming
designers and if so how does that
ultimately impact the revenue model
yeah ooh great question um so
it's what's between our immediate focus
for the sake of being able to like
refine our solution make sure that we're
creating value and then the long-term
vision
right now we're focusing on brands are
like somewhat established
um in terms of they have some sort of
digital presence where there's just like
a website
instagram which is like and like a
relative
audience but um that's for the purpose
of being able to ensure okay we
what we're saying that we're doing even
though we've seen some success
can we do this consistently repeatedly
now
in terms of the long-term vision since
we're looking to at least provide a full
suite of solutions that enable like
enable ease of operation across the
entire value chain
the vision is to be able to at least get
to a point where
an emerging designer who has an idea has
a concept but has no infrastructure can
come to us and be like hey
i want to be able to do work um and in
terms of how that impacts the business
model
where we're doing it is that we're in
that percentage will increase
as we take on services so what we've
done for more contacts is
we looked at comparables in terms of
what proportional revenue has gone to
the non-uh
personnel operations when it comes to
marketing production and distribution so
that's where the 15
comes from when we talk about uh
production is like
15 distribution 10 so that's going to
essentially
bring up that stack and that's what
we're looking to ultimately as we
provide
more solutions that percentage will
increase
all right thank you so much these are
really fantastic questions and really
great answers thank you all
very much uh and now i would like to
welcome ange to the virtual stage and
we'll hear the pitch from rivet
okay great so meet solstice fams and you
might not recognize me with the shorter
hair but there i'm working on my last
album
and performing and opening up for
grammy-nominated black which was
a big highlight in my career and
so here's actually how much it cost for
me to make a song from instrumentals to
mixing to
publicity and then i have two albums out
and on the cheaper end this is what that
costs
so imagine my frustration where after
thousands of players i go in and this is
how much i've earned after
that the problem is we're not getting
paid enough for
our music being played and unless you're
drake you don't make enough from
streaming
to really sustain your career that's
where rivet comes in
it's the best way for artists to build
and monetize their super fan base
artists are saying how do i turn passive
listeners into fans that stay and grow
with me
how do i make enough of these people to
create my art sustainably how do i know
everything about my top fans so i can
super serve them with me thoughtfully
meet ivy who is representative of our
beachhead market between 25 and 35
about 50 to 500 000 monthly listeners on
spotify and she actually has 300
000 so that begs the question with such
a large large fan base why didn't she
make enough to just focus on music
she wanted to increase revenue streams
personalized ways to connect with her
most loyal fans and drop her upcoming
merch for her project
this is where rivet is different you can
sell any and everything direct to fans
and that's exclusive demos
nfts one-on-ones and you have crm that
allows you to personalize communication
with fans everything from listener
behavior
purchase history and we gamify that in
dynamic fan engagement scores
and the final piece is the link hub
which is basically a mobile website
builder
where artists can host content and build
those email lists themselves and there's
an actual text
text from an artist we work with saying
it's like link tree on steroids i
couldn't have said it better
and for iv cellphone merch release this
was the earliest mvp and you can see
that this was exclusive merch with that
push and the impact was staggering went
out to 5 000 fans
over 10 000 in sales which is about 2.6
million plays of our actual music
or 250 years of listening time for a
two-week campaign with no marketing
dollars spent
now inside the actual product that we
built you can see here you can embed
anything from audio
video nft and your fans can unlock that
for free for
score or for cost in the crm you can get
granular down to the exact fan with
those engagement scores and their
actions in relation to you
and with this link hub you can see the
hosting content and artists being able
to grow those
communities themselves the market is an
8 billion market opportunity
a time of over 6 million independent
artists and with no touring in 2020 and
ad revenue down
artists were really striving for
increased revenue right now
direct to fan is the fastest growing
segment of the music industry
and it's experiencing large growth year
over year
our competitors as you can see in the
top left are people who serve our
audience but not quite with the solution
that we have
and on the bottom half it's kind of next
best solutions things like mass email
or crm that's too complicated and only
in the top
right do you see platforms that actually
serve labels but not quite with our
solution
and only two percent of people on
patreon actually make the monthly
minimum wage and it's not directed at
artists
our revenue model is a simple tiered sas
subscription
plus 10 on exclusive sales made through
e-commerce
progress that we've made is 72 customer
interviews that actually let us
pivot our idea from previously being
more analytics based to this fully
functional product that has 60 users
and that we've implemented a brand
visual identity for
and secured a pilot for the summer with
mba for africa which is 800 students
supporting five artists in the summer
our next steps
is fully getting mobile ready more
flexible options for artists to monetize
and some of our growth goals the team
right now is me
corey who's my co-founder is finishing
at drexel has worked at google coinbase
darklang the rest of our dev team is
berkeley and mit with experience from
tableau and clavio
and rachel our mit designers worked at
kudos which is another
music tech startup and our advisors have
experience operating and building
businesses for decades in the music
industry
the 15k is going to really take us to
the next level this summer we'll work
full-time on rivet
figuring out product progress as well as
our growth and distribution channels
across
content marketing advertising and
referrals to help us reach those growth
goals
help artists like myself and we want to
change the lives of artists like myself
and ivy by helping them make enough
money to create their art sustainably
so they don't have to rely on royalty
stealing
big label contracts or profit hungry
streaming services
and we can finally put the power back
into the hands of the musicians
we hope that you'll join us on this
mission thank you
all right that was exciting and wow
before i even get my screen into gallery
i see that gee has a question
so go for it um
so it's super interesting i think like
my question is
more about like you um as an artist
right
um we know all the you know the plight
of the music industry how badly
like the you know like the musicians get
paid for all of that
but talking about like the the the
technology there you as an artist
what do you think that you know in that
platform
makes it like very different from the
other platforms like what kind of
what what what is made easier there what
can you do there that you cannot do in
any other platforms
um you know what would attract the
artists themselves
the big thing is that one you can
account for engagement across many
levels i talked about
people purchasing people listening their
email behavior with you
and what they do on streaming and really
get a clear picture of your fan
engagement and be able to reward your
fans based on that
and then the other thing is that other
platforms try to do things like push
subscriptions onto the fan
and as you can think that's that's very
difficult for fans who like multiple
artists you're not going to subscribe to
every single artist doing something
but the same way you would go to
multiple artist shows maybe you buy
something when they release it to these
communities so having a more
content-based monetization strategy
i think is also a big differentiation
and it allows artists to create on their
own schedule
versus feeling like they need to do
something every so often for their
subscribers
as a musician you would say like because
like your platform is really dependent
on like how much the musicians are gonna
interact with it right like because like
part of the fun is like i go there and i
feel closer to the band
or closer to the artist from your
experience i think that's something the
artists
want to do they want to engage more with
the audience they would like to
be closer to them to use this platform
uh more yes and and now paint a picture
for you
um one thing that artists can't really
easily do right now is say
i want i'm going to detroit and i want
to know who my top 20 fans over 25
are that have spent x dollars on me and
i want to do something specifically for
them
there's no way to have a clear picture
to be able to do that across platforms
and take a decision with that
and that's super easy with what rivet
has built
okay thanks
all right i see that you are unmuted is
that because you have a question yes
there goes a hand absolutely so um
so to just kind of understand the the
business model for these independent
artists so this they
are you envisioning that they'll be able
to sell their music directly
uh so you who's going to be hosting that
music versus
having to distribute or or needing to
complement the distribution of the music
through
apple music or other
or spotify and what what does that look
like that business model for
for for from from the music
distributions perspective
especially that most people now really
just want to listen to music through
spotify or apple music they don't want
to get out of those
those when they want to listen to music
yeah so
the way we're thinking about it is
that's kind of the top of the funnel for
artists so artists are
the behavior switch there's some
behavior switch but it doesn't take away
those other platforms you're still going
to do the things that you do on
instagram on facebook on your spotify
and your apple music with your
content that you released to grow your
fan base but the
the idea now is that of that bigger fan
base you're pulling people here
where you can release other music to
them the way artists release deluxe
versions or songs that they record that
may never come out
or songs that are specifically for that
community you can release that
specifically
just alone to those people and we do
that hosting and monetize that
flexibly and price that without having
to deal with those other platforms that
take larger chunks
so it's it's complementary but artists
will
probably keep their most valuable
content within this community because
they know that's where people actually
pay
and then the rest will be for growing
that top of the funnel to get more
people in here
excellent thank you
and jen we have a we have one minute so
if we can wrap this
very quickly and quickly let's go for it
uh did i hear you right that there are
other platforms that are doing this kind
of work right now
i mean are there others that have that
kind of something direct to the
super fans those platforms that one are
not focused on
artists and two like i said push the
subscription fees to the fans
and then three don't allow you to
release content the way we do we're
saying that you can release to this your
super fan community
you can release music you can release
nfts you can release
audio video and all those things but
those platforms are really limited and
the one-time things that you can do so
on that content-based
schedule and then also the options that
you have for what you can actually
release
thank you that was great actually
perfect
perfect length of response and at this
point
we are going to go over to our last
pitch so thank you anj so much
that was really exciting and now sita
let's have you
and um caso you're up
okay perfect all right i'm ready to go
um
i'm so excited to share casa with you
all um i also have michelle here joining
me today
um we are on the mission to make
creativity more accessible for everyone
and we are a tight team of venture
builders product managers engineers and
designers
uh previously i was building new
ventures at ideo with a design led
lens and michelle was doing a lot of
different product leading roles at
uh startups um and we're very passionate
about the problem that we want to solve
and the problem that we want to solve is
we want to help more people
try out the fine arts it's difficult
today
so we want to share a story about rachel
rachel is a leisure creative
um she's someone that we talk to uh she
has a great career
very busy good income and wants to
explore the creative hobbies
outside of work she follows an artist
that she really enjoys on instagram and
wants to try out that style for herself
so what she does next is she goes to
book um when she enters black she's
confused by
all the different types of paints
acrylic oils watercolor
she doesn't quite know which one to get
and all the different brands as well
wins
windsor newton um blick uh
chroma it's just it's quite overwhelming
for a beginner like rachel
and also the hundred different types of
brushes is not helping
um so what she does is she leaves she
doesn't end up purchasing
anything um and as a result she doesn't
make her foray into the fine arts
rachel is not alone she's not the only
person who wants to try out the fine
arts but
um is stopped halfway so what we did was
we talked to a ton of people
like rachel and mapped out their art
creation journey
so this is the different steps that a
user like rachel would take
in order to make art and we mapped out
the joy that they experienced through
the different steps of the journey
what we found was in the beginning where
someone is inspired to create
they feel a lot of joy and excitement
and towards the end when they're
actually creating the art and that
creative flow
they're thrilled about it and very happy
but unfortunately
in the middle part where the person has
to learn about the process
the supplies buy the supplies and then
learn the technique
it's very complicated confusing and
unpleasant for beginners
and this is where we kind of see a
trough of despair for these kinds of
users and where we see a lot of people
drop off
and they don't ultimately make it to
creating the art
there are digital tools today that users
turn to
most people have sort of hacked together
their own solution for
how they make the arts they look at
tutorials on youtube or
zoom in on pictures on instagram to find
out what supplies artists have used
but there's no one go-to source that
takes people through the whole journey
what caso wants to do what we will be
doing
is evening out and love elevating the
joy curve
so that it's as pleasant to make art in
the middle parts of the process
as it is in the beginning and the end so
that more people can be creative
and what we'll do is three main things
one will build a go-to place for
beginners to try out the fine arts
we will provide guided processes for
them to try new mediums
and help them identify and purchase the
right materials
so i'm excited to share what our product
will look like
so this is caso imagine you come onto
the caso home page
and you're met with an explosion of
different types of art you can search
through for something you're interested
in
and click into an artwork that you find
that speaks to you
here you can view process videos that
the artists have put together
that show you key techniques and look at
the supplies that you'll need
what we're hoping to sell is the
different supplies that
are curated by the artist who has
painted each piece of work
they can buy the supplies a la carte or
purchase everything they need in a
bundle
um kind of a model
and we do uh think we're very
differentiated from competitors today
there are players like blick who retail
supplies
pinterest and instagram who serve as a
source of inspiration
for uh hobbyist and subscription model
lessons and individual art supplies but
there's no
one go-to platform for leisure creatives
like uh rachel and she's the one that
we're trying to serve here
this is a pretty lucrative market based
on analysis the tan
for uh people like rachel is roughly 700
million annually
um in the short term what we plan on
doing as i mentioned during the product
demo is to retail art supplies
then we want to create casa branded
products to give supply chain
transparency to users so think of
relaying for art supplies
and longer term we want to expand our
product selection and target additional
user bases
like older adults and children as well
our path to market is uh important to
have
artists in the journey with us so meet
zoe zoe is one of the artists that we
have been partnering with
if you remember the cat picture from our
product demo she's the artist that
created that
she has studied the fine arts but is
struggling to make a career in the arts
because it's hard to make a sustainable
income she loves teaching and sharing
her process with followers
so she's looking for additional ways to
make money increase her visibility and
build her brand
she loves the idea of caso and is really
excited to partner with us
in return we want to compensate her
fairly so we want to share um we want to
compensate her for her work and share a
proceed of supply sales with
artists like zoe and we're talking with
a bunch of
other artists as well um in order to
curate content for
um our platform these artists range from
with followers ranging from 2k to
um 100k um but they all have one thing
in common they love teaching others and
sharing the arts
so here are our upcoming milestones for
the rest of the year the key milestones
are this summer
we plan to partner with artists in order
to build quality content
and build a functional mvp website all
with the eye to fully launch in this
coming december
and we could really use your help the
15k creative arts funding will be
instrumental in helping us launch and
scale in the next few months
the majority of our expenses will be to
fairly compensate artists in return for
their partnership with us
and the rest will be dedicated towards
web design and build marketing
and supply inventory and shipping
so with your help uh we are really
excited to build caso
into the go-to platform for creative
making we will grow the creative
community together
and empower existing artists to do what
they love
all right beautiful it was very soothing
i enjoyed that
um great let me see if we have any q a
from our judges
jen go for it well i love this idea this
is great thank you so much for
um for sharing it could you tell me a
little bit about each of your
backgrounds and what brought you to this
yeah sure uh so i studied visual arts in
college and
unfortunately fell out of the arts for
um a while i was a consultant right out
of undergrad and then i moved to ideo i
was a business designer there
uh building new ventures with a design
like barnes um
and uh i've always wanted to get back
into the fine arts so i thought grad
school would be a great time for me to
do so
and uh in the beginning of last
september i went to blake uh walked into
black and
had this realization that the blick i
was in was the same blick i went to in
college the same book i went to in high
school the same one in middle school
the whole world has moved online and
made the purchasing and navigation
experience so much easier
in d2c models across all different
industries and the fine arts have kind
of stayed stagnant in a brick and mortar
model
so what we ultimately want to do is just
make it much more accessible and
pleasant to access the fine arts
so that's kind of a little bit about my
background and how caso came to be and
i'll let michelle share her background
too
yeah i'll be brief i worked in a lot of
startups as ceta said mostly in product
roles a little bit
of business development um and basically
met ceta loved her passion
have always wanted to have hobbies that
are off the screen
working with my hands and this was just
a perfect
marriage yeah
sorry i think we can go into the next
question
sorry for the background noise please
don't worry
about that um michael why don't we hear
from you and then from gee
great yeah no i'll be pretty quick i was
really just wondering if you have any
standardized
curriculum that you expect your artists
instructors to provide
are they obligated to some kind of
unique branded
curriculum for caso or is are they
allowed to pretty much come and bring
their own
unique approach wonder how you were
managing that michelle you want me to
take that one
uh yeah i can take it so the artists
we're working with right now are
submitting they're
already like the videos that they've
already created that are educational
as we kind of develop and work with our
content creators
we might templatize it so it makes it
easier for them but we want them to be
able to create
be expressive and share the art in the
way that they want to
great thank you all right why don't we
move on
to key okay it's just a quick one
oh it's it's a great idea by the way
like to connect that
um you know like the art that you see
like immediately with the how to
and like you know the exact materials
that you need i think that's a great
idea
i'm wondering like what's the share
there you know if i put
my painting up there and someone buys a
paintbrush
how what's what's the cut
that's a great question and and quite
honestly something we're still figuring
out we've been chatting with artists
about what kind of
uh cut seems attractive to them
typically if we were to look at a
affiliate marketing model which is kind
of similar
that's roughly 10 so we've been telling
artists roughly 10 to 20
is the supply revenue share that they
would be getting
and they've been satisfied with that
they it's an additional revenue stream
for them
on top of being compensated for creating
the um the art content videos and
curating the supplies
excellent do we have any other questions
okay then with that
i am before i turn things over to my
esteemed colleague susan wilson
i just want to say thank you to
everybody for these wonderful pitches
the chat is blowing up and i'm gonna cry
about how proud i am of all of you
and um you know these q and a's with the
judges were really fantastic
so with that it is time for some
decisions to happen
so the judges are going to be departing
for approximately 45 minutes of
deliberation
all right everybody thank you so much
i am delighted to let you know that the
judges have completed their deliberation
and after some really lively discussions
about all of these fantastic projects in
just a few moments we're going to be
ready to announce the winner
of the 2021 mit creative arts
competition
we do that i just want to remind
everyone here that each team who
competed in this finalist round
we'll be receiving a thousand dollars of
individual funding and so we're excited
to see what all the teams will do with
that funding
and what they will uh carry forward and
and achieve with that
so it is now my distinct privilege to
announce that the first prize winner
of the 2021 mit creative arts
competition
taking home 15 000 is
rivet congratulations
we're really excited for rivet for all
of our competitors i couldn't be more
proud of everybody who was on this
journey
on this process and thank you all again
to our phenomenal judges
to our mentors to our reviewers
to all of our workshop people to
everybody in the office of the arts
thank you to theo thank you to everybody
for being here
um you know i'm really excited about
this
thank you all so much and we are gonna
wrap it up
we will see you next year
thank you all very much congratulations
to team rivet but also that all the
competitors
and thank you thank you all for going on
this journey and being here with us this
evening
hope you have a great rest of your
evening thank you all
thank you guys nice to join you
you